warning the following video contains
spoilers is a freaking reaction video
what do you expect so we finally make it
to the capital and oh [ __ ] the server's
going offline for a few hours
how old is of nerds run Awad possibly
occupy their time we're off to see the
Wizard The Wonderful Wizard of Oz wait
wait wait wait wait it's [ __ ]
freezing outside with snow and the girl
still chooses to walk around in those
short shorts makes sense and now she
chooses to put clothes on when she's
back indoors logic awesomeness seen here
solid sneaking it up oh look a reminder
of the villains evil plan to research
mind control just so we remember that he
is evil and all and it's not just
because he's trying to marry a 17 year
old girl who's currently in a coma
what the [ __ ] of these things is there
they meant to be scary a system consoles
so simple even a 17 year old girl can
hack it this company must have the worst
security system ever watch out asana its
tentacle rape boring conversation about
high school yes you could totally be his
tutor since you've already shown how
[ __ ] smart and useful you are in
previous episodes sugu let me introduce
you to my waifu this is the vice
commander of the Knights of the blood
oath lightning flash Arsena I'm pretty
sure that's what it says in her business
card dude you're the most overpowered
character in the series [ __ ] you talking
about this is not tentacle rape hentai
no seriously totally not tentacle rape
ensign okay guys we've got the point you
can stop now okay I was just kidding
before this isn't really going to turn
into a hand side oh my god it's [ __ ]
hand tied thank you very much a one
Pictures for making me feel like I've
just been mentally abused and yet I have
the weirdest boner right now more
bulldozed in romance with a sister and
her Andy Chan cause you know they
weren't already enough stereotypes and
harem arts online yes you can totally be
a good sister by riding his dead little
sister a comatose girl and a 16 year old
gamer best love triangle ever oh don't
cry the one he loved is right there it's
just a shame you haven't figured out yet
considering they effectively look like
the same [ __ ] person oh my god
there's a [ __ ] etiquettes of lame
this game and here I thought it was just
a bunch of nerds pissing about online oh
wait I forgot the internet is serious
business guys so she's finally admitted
that she loves her brother yay incest is
win cest am i right follows oh wait he's
not really your brother remember he's
just your cousin cuz that makes it so
much better
well she go
quickly that couple looks so [ __ ]
wrong so fairy [ __ ] tells everyone
what we already know
and Crito freaks the [ __ ] out now if
only he'd come here sooner instead of
spending a few episodes pissing about on
[ __ ] and there he goes literally
ignoring everything he was told just
five seconds beforehand but what does he
care he's saving his wife